سجل مؤشر الرقم القياسي لاسعار المستهلك
في السعوديه لشهر ديسمبر 20022
ارتفاعا قدره نسبته 3.3 من 10% مقارنه
بالعام الماضي 2021
ارتفاع الرقم القياسي لاسعار المستهلك
يعزى بدوره الى ارتفاع اثار السكن والمياه
والكهرباء والغاز وانواع الوقود بالنسبه
تصل الى خمسه وتسعه من العشره في المئه في
مرتفع اسعار الاغذيه والمشروبات بنسبه
اربعه فاصل اثنين من ال 10%
تفاصيل اكثر حول الارقام التضخم في
السعوديه نستعرضها مع العنود العبدلي
دول العالم حيث ارتفع معدل التضخم او ما
يسمى بمؤشر الرقم القياسي لاسعار المستهلك
بنسبه ثلاثه وثلاثه اعشار في المئه في
ديسمبر 20 22 مقارنه بنفس الفتره من عام
20 21 اسعار الايجارات المرتفعه هي المؤثر
الاكبر في زياده التضخم كاد خلال ديسمبر
الماضي وفقا لهيئه الاحصاء السعوديه
الارتفاع الاضخم مشاهدينا كان في اسعار
ايجارات الشقق حيث بلغ اكثر من ثمانيه
عشره في المئه خلال ديسمبر الماضي على
اساسن سنوي خدمات الاغذيه والنقل والمطاعم
والفنادق سجلتها الاخرى ارتفاعا ملحوضا
والمشاهده في الرسم البياني ارتفاع اسعار
قسم الاغذيه والمشروبات بنسبه
24%
سجل قطاع النقل ارتفاعا باكثر من اربعه في
المئه في ممبار 20 اثنين وعشرين اما قسم
المطاعم والفنادق شهد ارتفاعا في الاسعار
بنسبه 86 اعشار في المئه خلال الذات
الفتره مقارنه بالعام 20 21 قطاع التعليم
في جميع مراحله طاله التضخم ايضا خلال
ديسمبر الماضي وفقا لبيانات الاحصاء في
السعوديه التي كشفت ارتفاع اسعار خدمات
التعليم في المجمل بنسبه ثلاثه وسته اعشار
في المئه ويعود هذا الارتفاع الى التغير
في اسعار التعليم ما قبل ابتدائي والتعلم
الابتدائي
فيديوهات من الرياضه المحاله الاقتصادي
محمد الامور استاذ محمد حياك الله في 2022
كان متوسط التضخم اثنين فاصله خمسه من
العشره ثم ارتفع في نوفمبر الى 2.9 اليوم
نتكلم عن
3.3 خلال هذا في ديسمبر ارتفاع هل يمكن
القول بانه في حدود المنطقي المعقول
المتحكم بامير بالقلب بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يعني ارتفاع مقلق لا لا شكلك لكن
لا ننسى ان تضخم هي مشكله عالميه يعني
تعتبر حاليا من اهم التحديات الاقتصاديه
التي تواجه العالم كله لكن بالنسبه
للمملكه تظل هي من ادنى المعدلات همم تضخم
ايضا قراناها مع دول مجموعه العشرين او
حتى مع بقيه الدول العالم تعتبر هي الاقل
يعني بين الدول العالم
وبراينا طبعا سبب رئيسي وارتفاع اسعار
السلعه عالميا وتفاقم الوضع للاسوء مع
الحرب الروسيه
عل اسعار المحاصيل الزراعيه القمح الذره
الشعير وايضا الاسعار الاسمده مما ادى الى
انها ظهرت ازمه عالميه في الحقيقه لكن
طبعا بالنسبه للمملكه تظل نوجه نظريه تحت
السيطره همم عاده في مثل هذه الامور
الجهات المسؤوله من اهمها طبعا البنك
المركزي
يحدون من التضخم بالتحكم بسعر الفائده مثل
ما معروف اسعار الفائده الان على الريال
السعودي مرتفع بشكل قوي جدا صحيح احنا
ممكن تؤثر على نمو القطاع الخاص نسبيا
وتحد من همم يعني نمو ولكن يعني بالتاكيد
من ايجابيات رفع الفائده هو الحد من
التضخم وبالتالي اليوم اسعار الفائده احنا
نتكلم بين 4:30 الى 5% الريمبو العكسي مع
الريبو يعني معدلات اعلى من التضخم اللي
هو ثلاثه ثلاثه
كان في اربع من العشره جالسين الدوري
او سنتين يعني يرتفعنا فوق ال 6% يعني في
اغسطس 20 20 وايضا في يونيو 20 21 كنا فوق
مستوى 6% لكن طبعا تباطا بعدها بسبب طبعا
الاداره الاقتصاديه الاحترافيه
الاقتصاد المملكه وبالتالي نزلنا الى
مستويات قرب الصفر تقريبا يعني الان صحيح
ان مرتفع طبعا السبب الرئيسي الداخليه
يعني هو اللي ارتفع بشكل كبير طبعا بسبب
ارتفاع اسعار المساكن لان اسعار الايجار
مرتبطه بشكل غير مباشر بارتفاع الوحده
السكنيه نفسها وقيمتها ايضا النقل كلها
المؤشرات هذه مع الاسف معدلات اعلى من
ثلاثه فاصله ثلاثه في المئه وهي اللي
السبب الرئيسي في هذا الارتفاع كيف يمكن
النظر الى تاثيرات همم استاذ محمد يعني
طبعا ما في شك ان هي تضخم مستورد بين
الدرجه الاولى بسبب اسعار السلع الزراعيه
المستورده بالدرجه الاولى اضافه طبعا الى
لابد من تقنين سلوك المستهلك يعني لما
نشوف افراط في استخدام همم الانثاق
الاستهلاكي تجاه المشروبات
والاغذيه والمطاعم بشكل في الحقيقه احنا
نفسنا
اجتماعيا فعلا ظاهره يعني غير طبيعي
لكن يعني في سلوك غير عقلاني في هذا
الجانب اذا تم السيطره على هذا السلوك
بالتاكيد انه هيحد على جزء كبير من هذا
المشكله تحديدا فيما يتعلق بالمطعم اسعار
المطاعم واسعار المشروبات
هل يؤثر بشكل او باخر على القوه الشرائيه
الموجوده خلينا نتكلم
لكن هل هي يعني متوائمه مع هذا الارتفاع
العدو اللدود لاي اقتصاد ودائما اي
اقتصاديين في اي حكومه حول العالم يحاولون
الحد من التضخم يعني لان يمثل ارتفاع
تكاليف المعيشه يمثل تاكل قيمه العمله
المحليه لاي دوله حول العالم طبعا
بالتاكيد هو مرتبط يعني لما نتكلم عن
الانفاق الاستهلاكي مرتبط بالقوه الشرائيه
للافراد ايضا فبالتاكيد اذا استمر التضخم
بالارتفاع بالتاكيد ان هياثر على القوه
الشرائيه المتاحه للانفاق الاستهلاكي
وطبعا لا نشاهدها بشكل سريع يعني تحتاج
بعض الوقت حتى نشوف تاثيراتها على القوه
الشرائيه
المتوقع انه نشهد ارتفاعات اكبر بالاسعار
لمرتبطه كذلك يمكن دائما تعريف ارتفاع
التضخم والتضخم هو مرتبط دائما بالاسعار
فهل من المتوقع نشهد كذلك ارتفاعا مازالت
الظروف نفسها موجوده ربما كذلك تتفاقم
يعني خلال الفترات القادمه ربطها في معدل
ارتفاع التضخمين ممكن يوصل بشكل كبير على
الوضع العالمي اسعار المواد الغذائيه
والسلع الزراعيه والاسمده لان هذا هو
المحرك الرئيسي لانه مثل ما قلنا هو تضخم
مستورد وليس يعني بسبب الطلب المحلي الان
مؤثر ناقته والبنك المركزي في المملكه
قاعد يقوم بدور جبار في الحقيقه
بارتفاع اسعار الفائده مثل ما قلنا ارتفاع
اسعار الفائده لها اضرار على النمو
الاقتصادي لكن ايضا لها ايجابيات على
التحكم في الطباخه واعتقد الان في ظل
اسعار الفائده بالريال السعودي اعلى من
معدلات الرقم هذا مؤشرات انها باذن يعني
الامور تحت السيطره لكن طبعا الاعوام
الخارجيه مهم جدا ان نشوف لها تهدئه
واعتقد ايضا البنوك اليوم
يعني الجهات المسؤوله في مواجهه التضخم مع
استمرار الحرب وكل يعني نتائج على كل
المستويات بالتالي ما الاجراءات الاخرى
التي يجب النظر اليها اليوم لمواجهته للحد
من التضخم بعيدا عن الفائده ورفع سعر
الفائده اللي ذكرته انك واحد من العوامل
المهم ومع الاسف يعني
قدامك اسعار الفائده وقدامك اسعار الصرف
يعني طبعا هذه اسعار الصرف لا يمكن المساس
بها باي حال من الاحوال وايضا سعر الفائده
ما زالت يعني البنك المركزي يقوم بدورات
المهم هو العامل الخارجيه طبعا في جهود
كثيره في همم يعني الاعتماد على المصادر
الذاتيه يعني همم لكن طبعا مثل ما معروف
همم في جهود كبيره باستراد ال- ال- المواد
الزراعي المنتجات الزراعيه من مصادر
للاستثمارات العامه واستثمرت جزء كبير
فيها هذا هيلعب دور كبير بالتاكيد بالحد
من ارتفاع اسعار
الزراعيه لكن في النهايه احنا جزء من
منظومه عالميه لابد ان يعني العوامل
الخارجيه هي اللي تلعب دور في الاجاره
محمد العمران الاقتصادي شكرا جزيلا لكم
حياك الله شكرا